Now,
the overwhelming narrative is that the Russians were very much invested in
having Trump win.
Right.
And if they were very much invested in having Trump win was the reason why they
focus so heavily on the African American community because the half African
American community traditionally seems to vote Democrat.
So they were trying to do something to break that up or try to do something to
weaken the position of the,
the,
you know,
the incumbent or a Hilary Clinton and maybe put some emphasis on Jill Stein or
some alternative candidates.
Yeah.
So the,
the way that the political campaign,
the political aspect of it played out.
So they establish,
they started building these relationships in 2015 and yeah,
they're doing this,
this tribal thing.
We've got our ingroup are part of this community.
And then what you start to see them do is,
um,
early,
they're actually,
there was a tiny,
tiny cluster in the early primaries where they were supporting rand Paul and
then they pivot to Trump pretty quickly and use and probably ran.
Paul just didn't pull well and they were like,
there's no way to get a lift here.
But,
but maybe Trump was getting,
you know,
some actual left in the media.
And so,
so you see them move into supporting Trump and then for the remainder of the
Dataset for from 2015 through the end,
which was mid 2017 or so,
is when this thing ends.
Um,
it's,
it's adamantly pro Trump on the right.
And on the right you see not only pro Trump,
but you see them really working to like a road support for mainstream or
traditional Republicans,
traditional conservatives.
You see a lot of the memes about like,
um,
are you with the Conservatives or the Konservatives in there,
you know,
and so the Conservatives of course are like,
they've got pictures of Lake Lindsey Graham and John Mccain,
the hate John Mccain.
John Mccain shows up a million times.
Um,
and,
uh,
Marco Rubio,
Ted Cruz.
Well,
I think that they,
you know,
one of the theories is,
um,
and,
and I believe this is probably true.
They,
they really strongly disliked Hillary Clinton because there was concerned that
she would,
you know,
things that she was saying about increasing freedoms in Russia were very
threatening.
Uh,
they thought the best bet to get sanctions removed was Trump.
Um,
so they had specific outcomes that they were hoping for.
And that was one of,
you know,
so there's always like a political motivation.
So there is this narrative around they just want to kind of like screw the
American society,
create divisions,
imply divisions.
When you look at the political content,
the clear and,
and sustained support for Trump.
And even more than that,
the clear disdain for Hillary Clinton.
There is not on Facebook and Instagram,
there was not one single pro Hillary post.
There were some anti Trump posts.
Because if you're running an LGBT page,
of course they're going to say negative things about Trump,
you know,
and,
and they're saying it.
So you should vote for Jill Stein.
There was early support,
um,
and some of the left landing pages for Bernie Sanders,
but you actually see the support for Bernie Sanders come in more after
it becomes clear that he's not going to win,
because then they're using Bernie Sanders as a way to say this was stolen from
him by the evil Clintons.
Um,
or Jill Stein.
You know,
here's a true,
a true independent,
real liberal,
uh,
we should be voting for her if we want to support a woman.
So there are these feminism pages really pushing this narrative of Jill Stein.
So you have the left leaning pages,
totally anti Clinton,
and then you have the right landing pages,
staunchly pro Trump,
and also strongly anti cruise,
Anti Rubio,
a anti Lindsey Graham,
basically ante every now what's called establishment Republican.
Um,
and there's this,
uh,
kind of pushing of people two opposite opposite ends of the political spectrum.
So this is where you get at the conversation around facilitating polarization.
So not just,
um,
it,
it wasn't enough to just support Donald Trump.
It was also necessary to strongly disparage,
um,
the kind of traditional conservative,
moderate center right in the course of amplifying the Trump candidacy.
Does that make sense?
Yes.
And it was a lot of stuff.
Yeah.
I use a lot of stuff,
but it does make sense.
And one of the things that was really bizarre to me watching the election and I
was trying to figure out is this because Trump is so bombastic and he's so
outrageous and he's just a different person that the way I was describing on
stage was that like finally the assholes have a king because they never had a
king before.
Like everyone who was running for president was at least mostly dignified.
I mean basically it's really difficult to go back in time and find someone who
isn't,
find someone who,
there's no one who insults people like he does.
I mean he insult people's appearances.
He calls them losers.
He called Stormy Daniels horse face.
I mean he said some outrageous shit.
So part of it was me think of like,
wow,
maybe he's just ignited and emboldened.
I actually had this conversation with my wife today.
She was like a I,
it feels like racism is more prevalent.
Like it's more,
it's more accepted.
People feel more emboldened because they're in their mind,
they think he is racist.
I can get away with more things.
Trump is president.
Like there's actually videos of people saying racist Shit and saying,
hey,
Trump's president,
now we can do this.
So I was thinking that,
well maybe that's what it was.
It just sort of like some rare flower that only blooms under the right
conditions.
Poof,
it's back.
Right?
But when you think about the influence that these pages have had in establishing
communities and this long game that they're playing,
like the LGBT pages,
even though they're shitting on Trump,
they really want to support Jill Stein because they know that'll actually help
Trump because it'll take votes away from Hillary Clinton that they,
it seems different like political discourse discussions online and social media,
the way social media reacted.
I mean,
there was a lot of people that were anti Obama,
uh,
before,
you know,
either either of his elections that he won,
but it seemed different.
It seemed different to me than this one.
This one seemed like,
like we had moved into another level of hostility that never experienced before
and another level of division between the right and the left that I'd never
experienced before.
And,
uh,
up like a willingness to engage with really harsh,
nasty comments and just to dive into it,
you would see it all day.
I mean there's,
there were certain Twitter followers that I think they're pretty much human
beings,
but I would follow them and they would just be engaged with people all day long
just shitting on people and criticizing this and insulting that.
And it seemed like it seemed dangerous.
It seemed like things had moved into a much more aggressive,
much more hostile and confrontational sort of chapter in American history.
If this is all done at the same time that is happening.
How much of an influence do you think this IRA agency had on all this stuff?
That's the,
uh,
that's the question that we would all like the answer to and unfortunately can't
give it.
And so in your mind though,
yeah,
let me,
let me Kinda caveat that.
Um,
the thing that we don't have that nobody who looks at this on the outside has,
is we can't see what people said in response to this stuff.
So I've looked at now almost 200,000 of these posts,
um,
as what I spent most of last year doing was,
was this,
was this research,
and we can see that they have thousands of engagements,
thousands of comments,
thousands of shares.
We have no idea what happened afterwards.
And that's the problem.
So when once the stuff comes down,
it's really hard to go back and piece it together.
So I can see that there are some,
uh,
per your point,
the really,
really just fucking horrible troll accounts that they ran.
They didn't necessarily have a lot of followers,
but you see them in there,
like adding people,
so they're,
you know,
at,
and then the name of a reporter at the name of a prominent person.
And so they're in their kind of like draft on the popularity of,
you know,
famous people basically.
Um,
and they're just saying like horrible shit and it's,
the tone is so spot on.
And one thing that was interesting with a couple of them is like if you go and
you look at their profile information,
which was also made public,
they would have like,
um,
they would have a,
uh,
like a gab account in their,
in their profile that was like,
so they would,
um,
so it was a remarkable piece of,
of,
of kind of the culture in which you see that.
Like they're actually sitting on Gab too,
right?
And so they can also go and they can draw on there.
In reddit,
there's,
you know,
900 something a troll accounts were found on reddit there on tumbler.
And so they're just picking the most divisive content and they're pushing it out
into communities.
And at the same time we can see that they're doing it,
but we can't see what people do in return.
We can't say,
did they just block?
Did they have the fight back?
Did,
was there a huge,
you know,
when this happens on a Facebook page,
um,
and they're doing something like telling black people not to vote,
as black people,
we shouldn't vote.
Um,
what do people say in response?
And that's the piece that we don't have.
So when we talk about impact,
a lot of the impact conversation is really focused on did this swing the
election?
We don't have nothing that I've seen has the answer to that question.
Um,
the other thing is,
but the second question,
the thing when I think about impact,
I think from,
from,
I think you and I agree on this,
um,
it also matters how does this change how people relate to each other.
And we have no real evidence of that with no information on that either.
This is the kind of thing that lives in some,
you know,
Facebook has it,
the rest of us haven't seen it.
No.
Are Most of these people,
is this mostly Facebook?
Is it mostly Twitter or where,
what does,
how does it break down?
Yeah,
so there were,
um,
here at my like little stats here,
cause that will give you the wrong data.
There were 10 half million tweets of which about 6 million were original content
created by about 3,800 accounts.
Um,
there were about 133,
I mean,
just read it.
133 Instagram accounts with about 116,000 posts and then 81 Facebook pages and
17 youtube channels with about 1100 videos.
And so they got about 200 million engagements on Instagram and about another 75
million or so on Facebook.
Um,
engagements are like,
likes,
shares,
comments,
reactions,
you know,
um,
so
it's hard to contextualize,
but what we think happened,
you know,
you can go and you can try to look at,
um,
how well did this content perform relative to other real authentic media
targeting these communities.
And what you see with the black community in particular is their Instagram game
was really good.
Um,
they're,
so they're on their Instagram accounts,
the,
you know,
the top five,
three of them targeted the black community and got,
you know,
um,
tends to hundred millions of engagements.
So I'd have to pull up the exact numbers off the top of my head.
Yeah.
It's,
um,
it's on Instagram.
It's all memes.
And then you know,
so we have the memes and then we have the text on Instagram.
You can't really share.
So it's amazing that they got the kind of engagement that they did.
Even without the sharing function.
One of the things you can do is if you know the names of the accounts in there,
a lot of them are out there publicly now.
Um,
you can actually see them in regram apps.
So,
uh,
people were regramming the content.
So Facebook says about 20 million people,
excuse me,
engaged with the Instagram content,
but what isn't included in that is all of the re grams of the content that were
shared by other accounts.
So the spread in the dispersion of this,
it's an interesting,
uh,
an interesting thing to try to quantify because we have engagement data,
but we don't know,
did it change hearts and minds?
We don't know if it influenced people to go follow other accounts.
We don't know if it influenced people to not vote.
Uh,
there's just so much more,
I think still to,
to understand about how these operations work.
Kind of,
we can assume that it had some impact,
right?
I mean,
yes,
as,
as you were saying earlier,
when a new person enters into a conversation that it changes the tone of it.
How much of what they did was their own original posts and how much of it was
commenting on other people's posts.
So I thought you were actually going to ask a different thing there.
Yeah.
How much of it was them repurposing our own posts,
right.
Repurposing real American content.
Um,
did they do that as well?
Yeah,
tons of times.
But let me,
let me,
uh,
so they created a lot of their own stuff,
particularly in the early days.
And so you can actually read the Dataset.
And one of the things when we started finding these posts,
I was struck by how sometimes it read like Esl and then sometimes it red lake,
perfect,
flawless,
um,
professional English.
And then other times it read like normal English vernacular.
Just the way that we would talk to each other.
And I started digging into what that was.
So when it was vernacular English,
when it was,
when it,
when it read like fluent in American American English,
it was,
um,
usually cribbed from somewhere else.
So they would go and they would find a local news story from some obscure local
paper and they would crib and then they would paste that.
And then,
so the Facebook post would be that cribbed a sentence from that article and then
their meme and maybe they would add a sentence underneath it to give it some
kind of context or angle.
When they would write their own stuff,
you would see the sloppiness.
That's where you could see,
um,
subject verb agreements,
not quite there.
The,
you know,
ways in which like Russian possessives are different than American possessives
the slips there.
Um,
and then the other thing was the really funny stuff,
which was,
um,
you know,
a post that's supposed to supposedly written by Texas secessionist.
Right?
So you can probably have an image of a Texas secessionists in your mind as I say
this.
And it would be things like,
um,
Hillary Clinton is a terrible individual and as a,
uh,
as a terrible individual,
it's completely impossible for us to back her in her candidacy for the American
presidency.
Furthermore,
you know what I'm doing?
It's like furthermore air go,
yeah,
it is clear that,
and I'm like,
it reads like member you're like in English in college or something.
You've got to like write a formal essay.
I was like,
okay,
come on.
Right.
So nobody actually talks like this,
especially not,
you know,
your gear,
Texas is action.
So it was funny seeing these,
um,
incongruities and that's unfortunately one of the best ways to tell what you're
dealing with is actually to kind of look for those incongruities now and see,
uh,
as you read communications online,
like,
can,
you know,
does this,
does this read like an American,
does this read like a communication?
And what we started to see was one way to not get caught for your lousy English
or your,
you know,
yeah.
Your cultural,
um,
lack of,
uh,
kind of native,
native,
um,
abilities is to just repurpose other people's stuff.
And so that's where you would see memes getting shared from,
uh,
on both the right and the left.
You know,
you'd see a lot of these like turning point USA memes that they were repurposing
and pushing out,
or you would see,
um,
occupied Democrats or the other 98%.
So memes from real American pages,
real American culture,
and they would just sometimes slap a new logo on and just repost it as if it was
theirs.
So it does in those instances,
read just like,
you know,
authentic American content.
And in many ways it is authentic American content.